i'm five and a half months pregnant oh
okay i didn't want to assume you never
asked me
say that not only did 23 year old hayley
slayton audition for american idol while
she was five and a half months pregnant
being on the show pregnant is actually
not going to be an obstacle for me she
met her hubby in the process too
during sunday's episode of the hit
singing competition show the iowa native
performed miley cyruses the climb for
judges katy perry lionel richie and luke
bryan
there's always gonna be another mountain
always gonna wanna make it move always
gonna be an uphill
[Music]
and while they were lukewarm on the
performance
there were some amateur moments but then
there were some real moments
i wonder if you could
begin to replicate those more i don't
want to send them to hollywood
if unless i really think they're going
to get in there and compete they also
noted that the baby was probably
pressing on her lungs making it tough to
hit those high notes something katie
said she totally can relate to after
welcoming her daughter daisy back in
2020. the baby is close to the lungs if
i can remember for sure there we go well
i had to drop everything down a bit like
a half step
singing so i feel ya i think women
lifting up women is so necessary so
important because if we don't who will
that's when the judges did what the
judges do and gave haley some pro tips
having a kid stand in front of you
and you know they're nervous and you
know what that feels like and you know
they want to be a star and you know what
that feels like and so i'm really
imparting wisdom
that i love because
when i see them i'm not looking at them
as a contestant i'm looking at it as
myself fight for it okay this is you're
fighting for
your son your future
your voice to be heard yes ma'am haley
gave it her all
so come on
give me a chance all right we got you we
we're gonna give you a chance
and the judges sent her through to the
next round in hollywood
yes mama
yes mama absolutely yes thank you one
two three
you're going to hollywood
you can see that there is a diamond
there and it's just going to take a lot
of mining a lot of mentoring a lot of
just like kid gloves and if you thought
hayley's happily ever after ended there
think again the singer revealed in an
interview with her local iowa newspaper
the gazette that she met her now husband
jordan miles during the early auditions
for season 20 in texas
haley explained that they got married
pretty quick adding that they just knew
quote i was already pregnant and he
stepped up to be a father and i couldn't
thank him enough for that we're very in
love we're very happy that we met and i
feel like another reason why i was on
the show was to meet him and while
jordan's audition hasn't aired on the
show yet he teased his appearance back
in february on instagram
and on sunday he praised his wifey
writing proud husband
and if all that wasn't sweet enough get
this haley welcomed her son jalen back
in january but before he made his big
debut haley told ai she did it all for
her little guy
i really want to show him to never stop
chasing his dreams in the future never
give up on your dreams mommy went and
chased hers
[Music]
you